movie theaters are not going to die
however they are shrinking I will give
you that but no they're not going to die
every year fewer and fewer people are
going to movie theaters at home TVs are
getting bigger and better and nearly
anything you want to watch can be
streamed on demand within minutes this
has led many people to proclaim that
cinema is dying that in a few years
theaters will share the same fate of
drive-in movies yet every year it seems
to bring some new cinematic event that
shatters records we all saw Star Wars
then we and people will have the
counter-argument saying that in a movie
theater you have the experience of
watching a movie with an audience and
that's very true that's a very powerful
experience but that's not really the
reason why we are going to pay 15
dollars to go watch our favorite movies
at the theater no the reason movie
theaters are going to survive and
they're going to stick around there's a
reason that is so simple it is often
overlooked
sighs if you've ever thought anywhere
that there might be a better way to
watch something gotten a bigger TV
you've gotten better headphones to
listen to something on your computer
that means you care about how you
experience content a big picture
saturates the senses and sucks you into
the world through the frame no too often
you hear the argument that well I have a
big screen at home
that's 60-inch TV that you just upgraded
to it's not as big as a movie theater
screen the biggest TV pales in
comparison to a 3,000 square-foot ultra
high-definition screen the 20 full size
speakers in the theater laugh at your
puny 5.1 surround system this experience
can only be had at a theater and you can
have a great home set up for watching
movies in your house that's fantastic
but your screen will never be as big as
a screen in the theater unless maybe you
have a giant mansion or living in a
castle good for you if you're one of
those people you look back thousands of
years you look at human art you'll see
this urge to have things captured big
it's not until you go to the news and
you just see how big Mark Rothko's
paintings are just yellow and red on the
square doesn't seem that cool until you
see it ten feet tall and you see the
texture and you see that vibrancy and
you see the color and it completely
absorbs your field of view look at that
the Pyramids of Giza or how tall
Michelangelo's David sculpture is
there's a desire to see this intricate
detail in this robust almost more
vibrant than life quality that you get
from making things larger it's just
something that humans want why do you
think we think dinosaurs are so cool
it's
a huge I mean there's already lizards
running around that are neat they're not
dinosaurs
now you might disagree that a large
image really just isn't enough to get
out of the house to go down the street
and pay money to go to the theater but
let me remind you that we as a species
will travel thousands of miles to go see
a single painting hanging on a single
wall it's really not that far-fetched to
expect us to consider to drive down the
street to go to our theater youtube
streaming services let's even throw in
virtual reality in there all that stuff
is affecting our lives at that pool of
media that we consume from is getting
bigger and bigger every day
then movie theaters are getting a
smaller and smaller portion of that pool
this has had an interesting effect on
the kinds of movies we see succeeding in
theaters so at the end of the day it may
seem too obvious theatres are going to
survive simply because the screens are
big that seems way too simple but really
it isn't because we have the need to
look at big pictures we have the need to
buy bigger and bigger TVs in your house
but houses only gets so big and we still
want that bigger picture and as cameras
get better those bigger pictures only
get more and more detailed and more and
more intricate and more and more
captivating so don't discount that
primal urge to want to see art all big
encompassing it right in front of you
capturing all your senses because that's
something that we will always need and
we are always going to want it
hey guys why do action scenes suck see
all these dumb trailers with these dumb
action shots and you were like oh my god
this movie's gonna suck even though that
shots cool